et voilà et voilà donc bonjour en direct
en direct de chartres chartres 2018 pour
ce circuit des gones al tv circuit
diagonale tv 2018 2019
ça va ça va vraiment être intéressant
avec chartres 15 et 16 septembre donc
c'est demain que ça commence à 15h avec
le blitz
bien sûr il y aura t'il yaakov qui aura
guliyev y aura marc henrie ammar houri
dit le tout jeune champion d'europe
corse
voilà très jeune et déjà très talentueux
ça va vraiment être intéressant
d'essayer de voir ce qu'il va faire dans
ce tournoi mes tibias cov champion des
pays-bas lé qui avait déjà battu anaheim
tibia cov un jour d'exception mais
guliyev qui avait remporté l'année
dernière le rapide de chartres et
d'autres grands tournois ou s'il avait
gagné le bit source
oscaro l'an dernier devint tout un tas
de grands maîtres guliyev qui est sur
ses terres dans son club ce qui va
réitérer son exploit de l'an dernier
remportée un des deux tournois pourquoi
pas les deux l'an dernier il ya un pelé
vous il y avait que spider tubes que le
grand maître fedorcio qui avait réussi
le doublé il avait aussi un superbe
doublé à châlons-en-champagne donc pour
cette saison circuit diagonale tv donc
début demain le blitz quatre minutes par
joueur à 15 heures ensuite on aura
perpignan en fin octobre avec une très
belle salle facile d'accès et on me dit
à côté d'eux à côté de la gare de
perpignan où on peut aller très
facilement il plein moyen de joindre ce
très beau très bel événement où déjà on
me dit qu'il ya des maîtres et grands
maîtres espagnols catalans qui ont déjà
réservé leur place pour ce très beau
tournoi
perpignan qui fait sens à son entrée
dans sept circuits des gones à la tv
strasbourg middlesex à sa deuxième
édition dans le circuit qui est très
beau tournoi aussi bien sûr beatty
rapide 27 et 28 décembre c'est un
festival qui dure quatre jours
nancy bien sûr le sans doute le plus
fort tour - le traditionnel de france en
rapide et blitz qui aura lieu les 23 et
24 février 2010 9 pour cette année pour
cette saison n'est sûr ça sera
un des points très importants de la
saison ce tournoi de nancy on aura aussi
bien sûr châlons-en-champagne qui fêtera
sa deuxième édition voilà qui a débuté
un petit peu l'an dernier qui va essayer
de confirmer son lancement à châlons en
champagne ça va être aussi un bouton une
très beau temps dans le dernier à chalon
avec ce doublé de fait leur truc
surtout qu'il y avait perdu deux fois
face au champion de france cadet mais
malgré ça elle avait réussi à l'emporter
c'était la grande surprise à revoir en
vidéo vraiment il avait perdu deux fois
fait dans tous face au jeune champion de
france cadet une très grosse surprise
soit sur la saison des plus grandes et
puis enfin lyon fera son entrée et oui
la grande ville de lyon fera sans entrer
dans le circuit des modalités de cette
année avec le club de lyon avec à sa
tête christophe leroy qui lance son
blitz et rapide lui aussi pour rejoindre
notamment donc ce circuit des gones al
tv diffusée en direct vidéo voilà pour
la première fois en france les grands
tournois d'échecs français blitz et
rapide diffusé en direct vidéo sur le
circuit diagonale tv.com demain à
chartres à 15 heures c'est le blitz
quatre minutes plus 2 secondes par
joueur tibia cov guliyev marque andria
maori dit la très jeune et talentueuse
andréanne à grotesque où la jeune
française
six fois ou sept fois championne de
france féminine chez les jeunes 3 3e en
juniors mixte et puis qui fait le
national féminin maintenant depuis
depuis trois ans qui qui court encore
après son premier podium mais qui voilà
qui progresse chaque année et qui peut
qui peut battre n'importe qui et
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas une surprise
ici à chartres avec un tournant qui
s'annonce une grosse surprise puisque 2
je crois que le nombre de participants
va à peu près doublé avec plus de 100
participants pour le blitz dès la
deuxième édition et bien il semblerait
que la formule plaît beaucoup aux
joueurs notamment la possibilité de
revoir
bien sûr ce tournoi en vidéo en tout cas
on attend un très beau tournoi demain
voilà donc ça sera à suivre toute la
saison sur des l'onac tv mais aussi bien
sûr surimi nos échecs y aura quelques
bien sûr quelques directs aussi en
direct sur les minots échec mais
attention c'est sur la chaîne diagonale
tv aussi point com que vous aurez le
reste des directs donc il faudra sans
doute suivre les deux chaînes pour
pouvoir suivre en intégralité ce circuit
les gones al tv en direct voilà
n'oubliez pas d'aller sur circuit point
diagonale tv.com pour avoir toutes les
informations sur ce circuit
si vous voulez le suivre en direct qui
et pourquoi pas pourquoi pas si si vous
sentez capable d'aller jouer ces
tournois aussi près de chez vous puisque
voilà on est quasiment sûr tout sur tout
le territoire maintenant avec notamment
lyon et perpignan congelés circuit on
commence à avoir un territoire assez
étendue et d'un peu partout en france on
peut venir jouer une étape de ce très
beau circuit diagonale tv et pourquoi
pas être filmée en direct sur la table
20 face pourquoi pas demain face à tibia
coffre ou bien guliyev ça c'est sûr ce
serait un très beau souvenir pour ceux
qui ont la chance de pouvoir jouer ces
grands maîtres voilà donc c'était cette
petite intro en direct de chartres
c'était aussi un petit test technique
demain ce sera en direct sur la chaîne
diagonale tv et puis pour le tournoi
perpignan il y aura il y aura un des
directs qu'ils se rassurent imineo échec
donc à suivre toute la saison sur les
deux chaînes
tchao a très vite à demain au revoir